le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la vie réserve
souvent des surprises et malheureusement
elles ne sont pas toujours bonnes
la maladie ou le handicap peuvent
s'imposer dans un foyer très
soudainement ce genre d'événement est
très difficile à vivre pour la personne
directement touchées par la maladie ou
le handicap mais aussi pour ses proches
ces situations soudaine et douloureuse
implique un changement de vie radical et
des choix très dur à faire quand on
passe toute une vie avec une personne
comment se résigner à la mettre dans un
établissement spécialisé
quand cela est encore possible certaines
personnes choisissent de s'occuper
elle-même du malade
une décision plus qu'honorable puisqu'il
s'agit de mettre sa propre vie de côté
pour mieux s'occuper de celle des autres
alors comment s'évader un peu d'un
quotidien posant vers qui se tourner
pour trouver des solutions
on en parle maintenant dans léa social
c'est à saint-andré que vie marie avec
son époux j suite à une maladie a dû
subir une lourde opération à la tête
depuis son époux ne peut plus assumer
complètement et dépend d'une assistance
permanente marie assume pleinement cette
situation avec beaucoup de courage et de
persévérance pour pouvoir s'occuper
correctement de son époux marie doit
mettre sa propre vie de côté les loisirs
et les moments de détente avec son époux
sont inexistants une situation assez
difficile à accepter par moment mon
quotidien dans c'était un peu plus
difficile un peu plus pour piquer parce
que quand je descendais ans mais j'étais
pressé de rentrer parce que avant
qu'elle était bien avait quelque chose à
fait logique me faisais mais depuis il
est opéré sa tête et nous maintenons et
c'est plus possible surtout rentrer
après l'opération jusqu'à huit à dix
c'était un peu stressant peu angoissant
c'est un peu
oui venez pas tranquille qu'on est en
ville et on est toujours pressé pour
rentrer parce que ce n'est pas parce
qu'il a fait beaucoup de mal à l'aise
quand il est rentré le but alors qu'il
faisait encore le malaise mais
maintenant ça va ré fait plus depuis son
opération
on pouvait pas sortir on pouvait parler
d'un disque là puisqu'on pouvait pas
pays
l'afa loyers malgré un quotidien pesant
mari et son époux accepte la situation
et continuent leur combat ils finissent
par se faire une raison et admettent
cette sédentarité forcé mais marie
apprend qu'elle peut bénéficier d'un
soutien proposé par le conseil général
motivé par le besoin de pouvoir prendre
un peu de repos et de loisirs
elle prend contact avec le service et
une infirmière vient lui rendre visite
pour évaluer sa situation n'a le droit
de trois jours de combats
donc après l'art au pied de ces là
devant moi et puis comme naïve la
réponse est presque pris un point à
choisir les dates pour aller que c'est
bien et puis bien la balle n'était
vraiment bien accueilli
on avait bien on a passé un bon moment
on sait jouer et
mais oui quand même mais heureusement la
nasa madame dans le cul bien c'est ses
personnages et le cul bien le tour tous
les cas elle est vraiment vraiment bien
mais voilà mes saipem et nous devons
chose et puis pas autre chose
et puis on change un peu ça fait un peu
le vide dans la tête que tous les jeux
le quotidien n'efface pas fait le cas de
marie et son époux n'est pas un cas
isolé
il y a beaucoup de personnes dans la
même situation qui ont fait le
respectable choix de vivre pour les
autres
grâce au dispositif répit repos ces
personnes peuvent casser leur quotidien
le temps dans ces jours et avoir le
droit à quelques loisirs s'occuper d'une
personne âgée dépendante s'occuper d'une
personne en situation de handicap
jeunes ou moins jeunes ça n'est pas
facile et à la réunion il y à 45000
aidants qui font de cette de ce lot de
tous les jours
mal leur vie et c'est vrai que de la
mise en place du dispositif répit repos
aide c'est zedan familiaux complété
aujourd'hui par le dispositif la case
grand air qui veut dire que baal entre 2
les familles peuvent aller avec la
personne a aidé pour garder un peu une
respiration elle même ces personnes ont
besoin d'être accompagnés ça vient
compléter la respiration que nous
offrons aujourd'hui au village corail le
vvf de singe
comme ce que nous mettons en place aux
thermes de cilaos alors n'hésitez pas si
vous avez besoin de souffler pensez à
vous et bénéficie d'
comme marie des milliers de personnes
s'investissent dans l'ombre efface
l'intégralité de leur temps à s'occuper
d'un proche
ces personnes bénévoles sont peu
considéré par la société
c'est pour cette raison que le conseil
général tient à appliquer et à améliorer
ce dispositif pour apporter à ces
réunionnais toute la solidarité qu'ils
méritent
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais